au festival d'avignon l'événement
théâtral
mercredi soir ce sera dans la cour
d'honneur médée d'euripide mis en scène
par jacques lassalle avec isabelle
huppert dans quelques instants nous
serons en direct avec isabelle huppert
elle incarne mais d une femme qui a
trahi qui est trahi par jason et qui
devient une mère criminelle pour se
venger de cette infidélité le texte date
de 430 avant notre ère
mais les paroles qu'entendront les
spectateurs de la cour d'honneur sont
extrêmement moderne comme le présente
maintenant daniel wolfromm et valérie
lucas suis pas auprès d'une mère a battu
car je les ai vus déjà jetés sur les
enfants l'oeil d'un taureau fou comme si
elle allait passer au crime il ne
renoncera pas sa colère avant de fondre
sur quels cas le cri venues du fond de
la grotte et celui de m'aider
la mère des deux enfants les pouces
déchu trahi par jason au profit d'une
autre sa vengeance sera terrible
je vais passer la vie non mes chagrins
dans mes douleurs seraient partis vers
une autre apparence de la vie va-t-elle
tué ses deux fils et leurs doutes encore
à aucun moment elle ne sait où elle va
on est loin du destin imposé par les
dieux de la grèce l'héroïne s'interroge
sur ses actes mais d en ce sens est une
tragédie moderne il y a dans ce texte
nous une formidable permanente
provocation aux spectateurs
atteignant il faut retrouver ce que ces
textes avaient de quelques voix
d'inadmissible de violence des
situations violence des mots la nouvelle
traduction de la pièce donne une vue
très contemporaine des verts d'euripide
du reste avec toi ou n'a finalement opté
pour salles au total ce qui sont
complètement en dehors du langage
tragique parce que d'habitude donc là
c'est bien un infâme scélérat ou dois je
pourquoi ne plus pleutres pourquoi donc
là c'est vraiment non c'est un bloc dit
j'arrête tout discours j'arrête notre
communication parle comme ça mais après
le glaude ça qui est intéressant après
l'analyse c'est le nom que j'ai pour toi
c'est le nom que j'ai pour toi la plus
grande violence que peu la langue votre
hélas de mourir et on son père à coups
de crosse mais quand m'aider disparaît
de la surface de la terre le mystère de
son double infanticide reste entier
c'est la complexité du personnage est la
petite-fille du dieu soleil
étrangement humaine